ludmila mikaël sociétaire de la comédie
française change est drôle c'est aussi
changer le geste
oui c'est changer de corps changer de
poids changez de démarche
c'est à se transformer complètement
selon les personnages ont généralement
on trouve les personnages à partir du
corps ça signifie que le corps n'est pas
toujours le même à travers les époques
non selon ce que l'on porte au pied
selon si on a un corset ou non selon
comporta chapeau kivu par la figure en
compterait selon l'ala les cheveux je
parle là l'exemple extrême parce que je
suis en train dé stig la nuit des rois
viola est à partir de mots j'ai le
costume que le personnage ses aînés
d'être ans garçons ça vous ferait
marcher autrement c'est parti des bottes
qui sont excessivement loup antignac la
démarche lourds et les hanches vivent
différemment c'est que la cambrure j'ai
essayé d'éviter d'avoir laissé derrière
comme ça et j'ai aussi pris beaucoup
plus d'assise sur mes jambes les jambes
assez écarté et le mes jambes se sont
renforcés
[Musique]
vous êtes une personne différente vous
bouger différemment
oui c'est que le haut de son corps ne
bouge pratiquement pas celle corse est
ce le corset wii qui oblige à ça et qui
entraîne une sorte de respiration
c'est un petit peu frémissante ce
vêtement qui montre tellement le corps
féminin oblige à une vie bref simple et
féminines à une vie excessivement
pudique et peut-être plus plus plus apte
ans c'est peut-être pour ça que les
femmes s'évanouissaient parce qu'on ne
pouvait pas extérioriser on est toujours
victime bout de son siècle ensemble
c'est le 18ème la villégiature dans une
robe grecque vous prenez instinctivement
dépose à l'antique je ne sais pas si
c'est instinctif
la forme de la robe est juste le corps
suit et je crois qu'il est effectivement
souhaitable de rappeler peut-être la
sculpture et la recherche de la beauté
je les grecs c'est une manière aussi de
tenir la tête de courber le coup tout le
corps participe des doigts de pied
jusque jusqu'à la racine des cheveux la
tragédie demande des sentiments énorme
donc les attitudes suivent
j'ai l'air c'est la description de l'ex
est donc automatiquement le corps peut
devenir excessif et je pense que de
jouer dans une robe excessivement ample
aide car on a tous le toute liberté de
violence est à la fois là l'importance
énorme de du registre vocal et du
langage du corps dans l'espace
[Musique]